[Music]  [Applause]  look at this  [Music]  we have trained our pastors for them to  be disabused of partisanship  for their lives of sacrifice for their  lives of service for the example that  they have been in this nation for  decades and for their vision for this  great country we thank you for  preserving them oh lord for such a time  as this  [Music]  god is telling me raider will be  president  [Music]  the spirit of god came upon me and i  started telling people in 2022 i'll  determine who become the president i  will determine who will become the  governor i will determine  prophetically because i didn't know how  it will happen  the president will be elected out of  this election will be the president of  all kenyans we also want to have the  moral platform to ask whoever wins as  president to embrace those who lost the  election that would be difficult if as  an organization or as the clergy we have  taken a stand to oppose all supporter  candidates